we're a big group of strong women that
takes risks riding motorcycles all the
time in the city which takes a set of
steel ovaries in my opinion but we want
to help babies he says no to babies
the club delivers process and
pasteurized donor breast milk to mothers
and babies in need both to Nick use in
hospitals and to private homes we focus
our service on the women's health issues
so this is complete fit for what we try
to do as a club the call for milk can
come at any time you can be anywhere we
pull up to the dock at the New York milk
Bank Julie brings out the milk that's
been prepackaged in freezer bags and
boxes we strap it down to the
motorcycles this is it the way when we
opened up the milk bank
I was actually stuck in traffic with my
husband and saw motorcycle rider
illegally driving up the center lane and
I thought why can't we use motorcyclists
to deliver milk in and out of New York
we collected from women that have an
excess amount of milk we process it test
it and distribute it to hospitals for
premature infants and to the community
at large Marla was born four months
early I brought Marlo home after 161
days in the NICU I stopped producing
breast milk and all of Marlo's doctors
required Marlo to continue on breast
milk because putting her on formula
would gravely endanger her life I had to
find a way to be able to give my
daughter breast milk and I found donor
milk since then we've been getting
deliveries from the milk bank we get
delivery once a month it's three hundred
and thirty bottles of three ounces
minor cycles is the sound of hope
[Music]
they're bringing life liquid life or a
small baby who I don't know every time I
give Marlo a bottle I start to think
about what's in there it's not just one
woman's work I know the hard work energy
labor love dedication and sacrifice that
goes into every ounce we don't waste a
drop around here it's some priceless
[Music]
home for me first of all as a peace of
mind where you come home and you're
always safe that's what home means to me
especially for my children before I
moved into this home six months ago I
was living in the shelter to get my own
home it was just breathtaking
but there was nothing in it
I'm Kristen Tsui and I'm a designer at
Hummel design everything in this
warehouse you see is donated we work
with homeless and domestic abuse
shelters with families that are moving
out of those shelters and into homes and
a lot of times they have nothing but the
clothes on their back that's where we
step in and we provide the furniture for
them but then we also go back and
decorate and provide like those little
details that make your house a home and
makes it your home without our help
about 46 percent of families coming out
of the shelter go right back in with our
help that statistics goes down to 1% I'm
a direct care worker and I work with
older elder people before I live in the
shelter the boyfriend that I was living
with was emotionally and physically
abusive to me one day I woke up and I
just said I wasn't taking that anymore
today we met with Danielle and we just
talked with her a little bit found out
about her backstory it sounds like she
has come out of the shelter and now has
been in a house with basically no
furniture she has a few pieces but no
beds no you know chairs no table so we
talked with her a little bit about what
she wants in her home we went to the the
home and we took measurements and just
walk through each room what dinner looks
at my house now we all sit together but
we sit on the floor the priorities was
to have my silverware bows and spoon
stuffs of things for us to eat out of
and ready to put on the floor for us as
we didn't have this when I first started
here I didn't realize that people were
living this way when you walk into a
home that is completely empty and
families are living there and have lived
there for months
it's shocking because you don't think of
it
[Music]
but on that Friday when we reveal a
house I just I just love the energy from
our volunteers to the families that are
getting these you know new homes really
I just I can't get enough of that
feeling and that's why I've stayed here
for for so long
I got no my kids are gonna be amazed I
haven't really told it was going on I
just told the neighbors getting some
beards so they don't even know that the
whole house is gonna be down so I know
they're gonna be a style and a half so
it just makes me very happy
[Music]
it's like a magazine
went from zero to a miracle with a hat I
love you all for this I mean this is
amazed
this is just happiness to me to be able
to walk into a home and have your
friends and family there and you're able
to just show them comfort and joy that
that means a lot to me and I hope that
one day I can give back just what was
given to me
[Music]
in Detroit over the last three years
over a hundred thousand families have
had their water Chanel
I can't touch water or drink water or be
in contact with water without thinking
about somebody not having it
[Music]
my name is Monica Lewis Patrick and I am
the president and CEO of Lee the people
of Detroit we're committed to the human
right to water low-income people in
Detroit are having a hard time paying
their water bill and they're getting
their water shut off when the water
department comes out to shut off the
water they mark it with a blue line and
for many of the residents it's known as
the blue line of shame some people's
water is only off for a matter of days
others water has been off as long as two
to three years the issue of not having
access to water is a really big deal
you can lose custody of your children
you can lose your property you can also
lose your quality of health it just
doesn't sit well with me our job is
really to meet that human need our
services are for those families they
can't afford to get their water turn
back on our water primarily is donated
and then we store it in one of our water
stations and then it is distributed out
to the community based on need the
deliveries that we do every week make
sure that the client has enough water on
an emergency basis to do some basic
things flush the toilet take care of
their basic hygiene prepare their food
over the last year we've served over a
thousand families water can unite us and
so it's out a belovedness that we
approach our water work I always like to
say I didn't choose water water chose me
[Music]
police say the shots came from one or
more vehicles over 1200 shooting to the
city so far this year it's time for
someone to step up and stop them in
violence
Inglewood is historically one of the
worst neighborhoods in the city of
Chicago and also in the entire United
States of America there have been
children murdered while sleeping in
their beds because bullets penetrated
the walls while they were sleeping
Inglewood is generally a place where no
one feels safe what brought me to the
corner of 75th and Stewart was a young
lady was murdered her name was Lucille
Barnes she was 34 and she was a mother
and she was just trying to break up a
fight and she was killed in a drive-by I
didn't know her but I was outraged and I
felt like at this point if mothers are
being murdered something has to be done
some people thought that it was too
dangerous to go and sit on a corner in a
place where someone had just been
murdered three days before we went out
we put on pink t-shirts and we went and
sat on the corner we got some hot dogs
and we fed people we talked to people
more importantly we gave out a lot of
hugs so we got together these moms who
have the time and who had the passion
for it and I felt that you know being
there and being a president and having
eyes on the street and eyes on the
children that it would interrupt and it
would prevent a lot of stuff that could
potentially happen while you're doing
that you're playing a game with a kid
that you may never get to play with we
want them to grow up together so that
when they're older they're not enemies
and they're not targets of one another
they're not shooting or killing each
other since we posted up on the corner
of 75th and Stewart there have been no
shootings on that block no shootings no
murders there hasn't even been as much
as a fistfight there's a sense of hope
that they didn't have before it all
because were mothers and you don't want
to underestimate the power of the mother
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]